there's a lot of risk and uncertainty in
the market it's a very challenging place
running this engine in the background in
your portfolio is just a way to
completely dominate uh things like the s
p 500. there's all this controversy
around warren buffett when he said that
he could guarantee that he could make 50
returns if he was only managing a
million dollars and everyone kind of
wants to know
how and the amazing way is there's a lot
of ways that he would do it if your
viewers
implement this i'm sure they're going to
make a lot of money
hey believe nation in today's interview
i sit down with matthew peterson a value
investor he runs matthew peterson
capital and since inception 10.5 years
ago
he's delivered one million dollars would
turn into now 5.2 million dollars which
is 17 annualized rate of return per year
uh outperforming the s p 500 index fund
so
we go over everything from how to build
wealth investing and a very specific
strategy that he uses
to really compound capital and
outperform the market so with that being
said please sit back relax and enjoy the
interview
welcome to the channel matthew very
excited to talk to you to give the
audience some background and for you as
well basically i i interviewed phil town
and uh on the question we talked a lot
about you know investing and building
wealth and and one of the questions i
had for him was hey you know as as i'm
stockpiling cash for my business and
other people are having cash in their
bank accounts inflation rising and you
know like what do we do
to you know in finding investment
opportunities is really hard right now
what do you what do we do and he
actually brought you up in the interview
talking about a strategy around options
trading and how you could actually be
the house and not lose 90 percent of
your or 99 of your money like most
people use options trading and this was
very different
and so i'm just super excited to kind of
now go to part two after talking to phil
and now about to talk to you about what
is the strategy that if you're willing
to really put in the work for people and
it's important everyone knows this
really put in the work on how this could
actually be a wealth building
opportunity for those who are interested
like myself
and the viewers so i'd love to know
starting off um for options uh
what are they um calls and put options
for the viewers to understand and then
we'll move into
as the interview progresses more complex
things but starting off right there
thank you jeremy that's a great
introduction uh it's nice to see you
again it's nice to be with you the last
time we were together we were
uh dining in switzerland so uh i'm glad
we were able to to make this all work uh
i'm happy to to jump into um i'll talk i
think really quickly about the simplest
forms of these contracts and then as you
mentioned we'll go into some of the
complexities there's such a unique
situation going on right now so i'm very
happy to share this with you it's it's
really the first time uh that we've gone
public and talked about this and if your
viewers implement this i'm i'm sure
they're going to make a lot of money so
why don't we talk about the basics you
asked about calls and puts and uh so
basically a call is a is a option
contract that gives you the right to
purchase stock at a specific price at a
specific date in the future uh so you
buy this contract and it's tradable on
the exchange you can buy it through the
chicago board of exchange
and you're basically uh you know you
choose any underlying equity like just
whatever you'd like to choose you can
call it apple and in instead of buying
apple stock you want to buy a call on
apple you choose the price that you're
willing to pay for apple
um a certain period of time in the
future it could be three months six
months a year and uh and you'll pay a
little uh premium for the right to buy
apple at that price in the future and
then the outcome uh is it's either in
the money or out of the money so if the
price of the stock is above the price
that you're willing to pay
you still have the right to buy it for
that price that's what you bought you
bought the right to pay a certain price
and um if the stock price is below the
price the contract expires you wouldn't
pay more than you could buy it from the
stock market and so it just expires and
you can you can go about um buying stock
a different way uh a put
is exactly the opposite um so if we took
a generic example um and said abc shares
are selling for 100
the traditional use of put which is not
how we're using them but the traditional
use of the put is to protect your
portfolio so if you hold abc stock and
it's selling for 100 and you think
uh you know something about the shares
and you're worried they might decline
you could purchase some protection so
maybe you'd
purchase the right to sell the stock to
somebody at a certain price at a certain
date in the future so you might say well
i'm happy to take a little volatility
but if it falls below 90 i'd like to
sell
and um and so you would pay a premium
for that right to sell it and so maybe
you pay let's say five dollars so um
you're gonna go out six months and
you're gonna say i'll pay five dollars
now and it falls below 90 i still get to
sell it for 90. so if it drops from 100
to 50 you still have the right to sell
it for 90. uh and so
um that's how a put protects you and
most people think of calls and puts it's
terms of i'm buying them so you can buy
a call it gives you the right to buy the
stock or you can buy a put and it gives
you the right to sell the stock
does that all make sense it's pretty
basic fundamental
option information
the way that we're going to get into
here is all inverted and but it's really
simple so
instead of
using a call to buy the stock because
you buy the call
we use the put to buy the stock because
we sell the put
so
the put buyer allows you to
uh basically sell the put or put the put
to someone else
at a certain date in the future if the
price falls if i
sell the put
what it does it gives somebody else it's
under writing the the option contract
it's underwriting the underlying equity
so it gives somebody else the right to
put their shares to us so in a
hypothetical abc
uh stock equity situation trading at 100
the way we think about things and very
advantageous way of thinking about
things is that
we we approach this from a value
investing perspective we're looking to
buy shares when they go decline in price
we're not looking to sell shares when
they decline of christ and so if we know
about something about the underlying
business if we know something about the
management team the quality of the
management team and we know that it's a
very fair price
for this business
uh
and the shares
decline it actually entices us to buy
more and so in a situation where we want
to be buying the shares instead of
buying them in the new york stock
exchange for a hundred dollars a share
let's say that's what they're trading at
today
uh we would instead sell a put contract
committing to buying for ninety dollars
a share
and somebody would pay us
five dollars for the right to sell us
the shares if they declined to 90 and
then further if they decline to 90 or
beyond
uh
our net cash outflow then becomes only
85 because five dollars was paid so
we're literally lowering our cost basis
to a price below
the stock market price so we are not
paying retail prices for the stock this
is like a heads i win tails i win right
so it's like either you get it what you
want it or if you don't you do get a bit
of extra cash flow coming off of that
that's exactly right so uh if you want
to think about it like this there are
essentially four major buckets this is a
common question that people ask we're
sort of so let's say we started in
options 101 now we're in options 201
okay so in options 201 people always ask
well what what are the potential
outcomes okay so you write a point on a
stock that you want to own
uh there's sort of four
uh fundamental buckets that could occur
uh and the the mindset so keep in mind
everything needs to come from a value
investing perspective i run a long-term
value based fund right everything is
coming at this from a value lens so this
is how to use options
uh with a with a value bet to it uh so
there's four basic underlying buckets uh
always think about this as owning the
notional equity value so if you
committed to buying a hundred shares uh
for ninety dollars basically a share
you're basically committing ninety
thousand nine thousand dollars toward
this transaction in terms of emotional
uh so what happens is once you own the
shares a few things could happen and not
once you own the shirt but when you've
written this contract one you could be
totally wrong in your analysis okay it
would be a terrible
the worst situation is the shares
actually go from 100 to zero all right
so instead of losing 100 where you had
bought the equity you now lose 85
because you bought for 90 and you paid
were paid five so you actually
decrease your absolute loss you lower
your risk it's a risk reduction
mechanism but it's still a terrible
outcome obviously the shares just
declined to zero all right that's one
scenario the other scenario the most
attractive scenario
is that the shares go from 100 and they
decline to just below 90 they're put
into our portfolio they only cost us 85
a share and now instead of buying for
100 uh we got paid to wait we own the
shares and as the stock appreciates uh
we get we have a lower cost basis and we
literally have a higher irr our
annualized return
is greater uh and
so that's scenario two scenario three is
the shares don't decline below 90 and we
keep the five dollars on our 85 dollars
in uh collateral and i basically chose
these sort of silly numbers but um you
know it basically becomes a five 5.8
almost six percent return i set a six
month contract i believe so we're
talking about six percent uh over the
course of six months which is just fine
you could actually get quite
significantly higher returns this is
this is a really basic scenario that's
the third outcome so the contract would
then uh conclude and you would keep the
premium so you'd make your your
very reasonable irr uh the fourth
scenario is you are correcting your
analysis and the shares go straight from
uh 100 to 300. you do in that case miss
the upside that's an unfortunate
situation but nobody seems to complain
uh
typically you can earn a lot more like
10 20 or 20 plus irrs with these
premiums so you're basically capturing a
20 something plus irr in the premium but
you've missed a 200 percent
gain so i used a really small number i
just set a five dollar premium on 90
stock that's probably not sufficient but
uh you may be able to do it you may be
able to get significantly more you might
get 10 or even 15 on a 90 strike price
in order to not miss that 200 percent
upside do you
allocate so you do have a portion going
into this company you love to buy you
want to get that strike price um
do you go in at a position where um
let's say it goes to
90
or yeah it falls to 90 you get you get
put the stock
and then it falls to say like
seventy eight dollars or
eighty dollars so another ten dollars
comes off do you then do another um
options bet or do you actually just
decide to put in a second tranche of
just
capital into it without doing an options
call that time
great great question so um
and this is we're we're we're still kind
of in the 201 phase maybe we're getting
into the 301 uh it's very different if
you're managing a
uh
you know a fund like ours uh or if you
have a very sizable uh
you know
personal account
uh versus maybe a typical retail
investor with a hundred or
maybe up to a million dollars so you
would approach these in different ways
uh but what you're basically asking is
would you cost average or not so you
would have to evaluate your total
notional exposure you'd have to look at
the
percent allocation that you want within
your portfolio and if you have
sufficient capacity to
buy more uh you do your analysis and you
consider potentially selling another put
and that's exactly right so you can cost
average if things do decline further and
um and certainly it's something that we
do and yeah you'll you'll of course get
paid another premium and and potentially
higher irr so that's a very good
question it's nuanced for every
individual portfolio so
it would have to be considered on a on a
portfolio by portfolio level um
but what i want to get into here
i want to kind of accept this baseline
at 201 where people understand
we're inverting the use of these calls
and puts
in a very unique way most people have
trouble
if they if they've learned it the wrong
way first they have trouble
shifting their mindset to this but we're
basically looking to use these contracts
not as speculative products in any way
we're not looking to trade these
products in any way we are literally
using them as a tool to purchase the
underlying equity so instead of buying a
call to get that stock which is our cash
going out
we sell a put to get that stock so
somebody else pays us and then gives us
their shares and so we get to buy the
shares for less than they would cost the
new york stock exchange less than they
would cost to any retail investor we're
doing what i called what i call
structured value so we're basically
looking for ways to just lowering our
purchase price increasing our margin of
safety and getting access to these
shares so this is the fundamental
baseline that all the viewers need to
know before i get into this really
unique situation
that is
uh
happening right now and i and people can
make a fortune and and it's
individual investors can can apply this
i really encourage people that
understand it to put it to work because
i it's quite lucrative at the moment
yeah and it's uh i'm very fascinated for
you to dive into 3.0 and then 4.0 um
already listening to this because i was
shocked to hear that warren buffett is
also a huge options
uh yeah
as well
so
at this baseline level that we're
discussing
warren has had a history of of going in
and buying entirely companies using
short put contracts so people think
oftentimes because they learned a
b-school or something that options are
risky and they're you know for
speculation but if you use them properly
they can be really advantageous so um
buffett was selling puts on coca-cola
when he bought uh 10 of coca-cola uh he
also was selling puts on burlington
northern railroad when he bought the
entire firm
back in i think 2007 and it's quite
remarkable if you think about
what buffett is able to accomplish so he
goes out and he sells puts and gets paid
premium on i don't know how many
millions and millions and millions of
these contracts he was able to write but
he's out there writing these contracts
collecting premium
and then he puts in a bid for the whole
company above the strike price
of all these contracts so he just gets
paid and then he buy and then it of
course never goes down so uh he just got
all this free money and it really lowers
his his cost basis so when it's
available
and this isn't always available but when
the situation is available
even buffett at this level with you know
allocating billions and tens of billions
in a single time will attempt to use
this strategy so this is uh
it's it's fairly sophisticated it's
pretty advanced but i know quite a few
uh professional and retail investors
that are
using this in a in a certain way
that's that's amazing
okay so and i'll actually elaborate that
on with one more point just to really
drive it home i figured this out in
about 2005 i was working on wall street
doing consulting for goldman doing risk
management work and i was dealing with
all these different products within the
firm
writing all these
sort of
helping them with model validation
things and recognize that instead of
buying the stock directly you could
write these puts and just combine it
it's little algebra and you basically
end up with a lower purchase price
and uh
you know over the last 17 years this is
the only way i would buy securities it
does it seems
unfathomable to me to just buy a stock
in new york stock exchange uh because i
can just turn around and i just sell a
put and it could expire in a week and i
still get a lower price
so uh so i always use this and when it's
when it's possible whenever it's
possible i use this i can't fathom doing
it the older traditional way uh and so i
encourage you know the folks that can
understand this to try it you know keep
in mind an option is 100 shares of stock
uh so you know don't go and
overexpose yourself but uh but this is a
very advantageous and you learn a lot
just by doing it once or twice and
watching how it all plays out now
i think uh we're ready to move into
a more complex application of this uh
something that we figured out over the
last couple years and have made enormous
returns with what i'm going to talk to
you about is something that we call
internally
structured dividend capture it's super
awkward name but that is exactly what
we're doing is we're literally ripping
dividends out of the market it is not
the traditional use that i was just
talking about we're not high frequency
traders but it's a lot more transactions
than we're traditionally uh used to uh
but it's so lucrative right now that
especially in this challenging market
where we're dealing with inflation and
we're you know still on tail ends of
pandemics and we have you know wars
taking place there's a lot of risk and
uncertainty in the market it's a very
challenging place um running this engine
in the background in your portfolio is
just a way to completely dominate uh
things like the s p 500
let me quickly
share with you what is
you know what are we going to be talking
about what is structured dividend
capital so basically uh there are uh
so these contracts are priced based on
the black trolls model and there's five
greeks one of the main greek that we're
kind of thinking about right now is
volatility and we're in a period where
there's a lot of and it's always local
ball with various companies so we're in
a period where there's a lot of
volatility and showing up and there's
actually a volatility to volatility so
markets might not be volatile uh
tomorrow but uh next week they're
extremely volatile and so those are
what's changing option prices in a major
way there's other factors like time and
things why don't i go ahead and start
kind of sharing a screen here
because what i'd like to do
is
walk you through
how this came to be i think this
background is going to help your viewers
understand i'll go very quickly here how
did we come across this all right so we
have a four-step process for our own
portfolio management
uh and it starts with i've talked about
this a lot in the past so if people
aren't going to any other uh videos they
can go and look at detail but it starts
with this quarterly 13f analysis so uh
we're looking at say 100 super investor
13fs uh we're looking at all the shares
that they're buying and selling it's a
big advantage and it basically narrows
down the uh
world of investing from like 10 000
potential securities
to
a few hundred potential securities okay
so uh if you look at long-term
value-based concentrated funds they may
have billions of dollars but they have
seven holdings and it becomes very
interesting to see
people like bill ackman buying and
selling something or david ironhorn or
guy spear buying and selling something
and it and it's interesting and when
they're putting this huge allocation
into a new opportunity they spent
hundreds of hours
thousands of hours maybe millions of
dollars researching the opportunity and
their own conviction has allowed them to
put a huge percent of their portfolio
into that so it's a really interesting
thing to go and look at um so that's
where we start and we narrow down the
world of investing to
a few hundred securities we then go into
our fundamental analysis which has
determined what the intrinsic value is
of these companies and if we can
understand why there's a big discount
why it might close why this great
opportunity becomes very attractive the
next step is to apply its structured
value which i just explained so that's
applying the option strategies figuring
out how we're going to buy and as a i'll
of course mention when we sell a
security hopefully we don't have to sell
for a very long time
because that means it's just compounding
and compounding but when we do sell we
would use a covered call which would be
a short call a sale of a call to exit so
we get paid a premium to leave just the
same way we use a
short put
to enter and then position sizing as our
final step so this becomes
pretty uh important because what
happened in march 2020 is we were i was
doing our 13 f continuing with our 13 f
analysis and as the 13 apps were being
filed i noticed that the total super set
of companies had nearly doubled which
meant that all of these
investors we follow were diversifying in
a major way and i also noticed that a
lot of their purchases and this is just
helpful information as you're managing
your own portfolio but i noticed a lot
of their purchases were going into
really high dividend paying
stocks so suddenly folks were more
interested in an atn t that pays eight
percent dividends
then uh you know maybe uh
amazon or google and whether they're
right or wrong is irrelevant but the
amount of high dividend pair securities
that moved into the 13f bucket was
remarkable this is an old strategy but
it made me realize that because the
price had fallen and some of the
dividends
you know payers were maintaining their
payout ratios the yields were really
high and in the past people have tried
to
buy a stock right before you know you
get this dividends are different than
bond yields like bond yields accrue but
a stock if you hold it on the ex
dividend date and across the date of
record which is usually the next day
you get the you could sell the stock up
for that and you get the dividend
out maybe a month later so you just need
to really hold the shares across a
couple days so this isn't new
information uh there's been a lot of uh
research out there and people out there
who have tried to buy before a big
dividend and then they sell after the
dividend and uh efficient market
hypothesis would kind of say that the
price would decline a little bit it
doesn't always quite work that way it's
an okay strategy it it it's fine one
thing that's interesting this doesn't
scale what i'm about to tell you doesn't
scale to
the major players you can't put
trillions of dollars in this i don't
think you can even put
uh you really couldn't put a billion
dollars in it we run a modest size fund
but you can easily put
10 or 20 million through this and you
can certainly put 100 000 through this
uh and it always reminds me there's all
this controversy around
uh warren buffett when he said that
uh he could guarantee that he could make
50 returns if he was only managing a
million dollars and everyone kind of
wants to know
how
uh
and the amazing way is there's a lot of
ways that he would do it and
i think that this is
this is kind of one of the types of
things that he would do he's not
necessarily going to do the traditional
buy and hold route if he has a million
dollars he's going to do something
pretty creative and he's going to be
ripping 50 returns on the market i'll uh
show you here what what we're talking
about real quick step back this is like
a 13 this is our this is how i track our
13 f analysis internally so this is just
an example uh this is you know
old data but uh but this is how it works
so we pull and we look at what shares
are being bought what's being sold
what's being held we look at the
superset of all the data and it's very
helpful in just guiding our fundamental
analysis as i mentioned um and this is a
really good example sorry just run
through this presentation but it's
helped to repeat to give everyone a
pressure
how do you buy a share of stock for a
hundred dollars we sell this put so in
this scenario uh if anybody wants to
look and read through all the details
we're basically saying we're committing
to buy shares for 100
over the course of a year somebody's
paying 25
in premium for the commitment to buy
that stock and we then hold 75 dollars
of our own cash and collateral and the
25 they paid to us which makes the
hundred so we're able to buy the shares
and then there's a binomial outcome
either the shares are below 100 and we
buy the stock and it only costs us 75
because 25 money or it's above 100 and
the contract expires and we've made 2575
which is a 33 return in a year okay so
we either get the stock for 75 which is
great so when the shares appreciate to
you know 750 we make 10x whereas the
person who paid a hundred dollars only
makes seven and a half hours
uh
and and alternatively we make 33 so
the binomial outcomes are both positive
in the event that the shares don't don't
go to zero or like the first scenario
described
so here's an example once again about
how output now
let me jump into this we're going to go
quickly now into like the 4.0 uh level
so now everybody understands how to sell
a put everyone understands the strategy
and that we're looking at how to capture
these dividends
what i realized is that
if we sold a put that expired
just a day before
the next ex-dividend date of one of
these high dividend paying stocks
we would collect a premium for the put
then hopefully we put the shares and if
not it's okay we still make a good io
but then hopefully put the shares and
then immediately receive a dividend
and then we sell a covered call
immediately afterward
and get paid another premium and we exit
and so we actually get three payments
instead of just the dividend so we make
a put premium so our our costs go down
then we get paid the dividend
and then we sell the call and we pay a
call premium and we exit so what does
this look like
uh i looked around at some of the i did
in pain box and here's one uh for kkr
now you'll have to bear with me because
the prices are all changing and some of
this some of this data is from 2021
but uh but you just go and you look up
the current prices and you apply it to
today's uh
current market prices you're only
holding these shares uh for maybe a few
weeks maximum
so what happens here this is for kkr all
right so and this is a relatively small
dividend to be honest uh so what you can
do here and we're just using these gener
this is not a generic example so i'll
just go through the dates without the
year you sell a put
expiring november fifth with a strike
price of eighty dollars for two dollars
and sixty-five cents okay so you're paid
265. now
uh just
a few days later november 11th
you take possession of the stock
the next day you receive
a
small in this case 0.2
dividend
you then turn around and immediately
sell the call
and then the call expires and here's
what it looks like you pick up three
percent on the put you pick up point two
percent for the dividend and you pick up
three percent on the call and in total
by the way there's a few little rounding
things here
over twelve days you pick up six point
eight
percent which is an annualized
650 percent gain
okay so 600 this it's so astronomical
but the problem of course is that
dividends are traditionally paid four
times a year so you can only do this
four times a year all right so but it's
something to keep in mind so if you're
looking jeremy and you have your
favorite
you know equity position out there and
you know they pay a large dividend you
can do it you could just do it ad hoc
but right before the ex dividend date
you could have you could practice this
and you could watch it all play out over
the course of a couple weeks and make it
very very cheap
and this is uh so just to be clear this
is looking at companies that you
you do firmly believe in this is not
just you know going off
yes that is correct jeremy i don't mean
to interrupt you but um
so how do we treat this in our portfolio
we have a basket of these going on and
we have about 20 of the portfolio
allocated to this particular strategy
but this is very different than the more
traditional approach so we run
for anybody who doesn't know me well
jeremy i'll just say that we run a
long-term value-based portfolio peterson
capital management we've been doing it
for over 10 years and we are
fundamentally using this structured
value strategy to enter into positions
but ultimately we own these businesses
where we own a few percent of various
firms and we truly think of ourselves as
owners and we hold them for the long
term our longest holdings over 10 years
so we are not traders we are not
speculators we there's i've put a lot of
work out on
daily journal and a few other companies
that some people may be familiar with so
this is a
this is a more advanced
much more transactional in nature
strategy but it works very well right
now with heightened volatility on high
dividend paying stocks especially in
this time with all this great
uncertainty so
to that point
traditionally and typically we are
buying and holding companies with huge
conviction where we understand basically
the
we're looking for the greatest business
models in the world okay so this is like
today in today's world this is like a
sas business that's just an outstanding
business model then we look for the
greatest management teams in the world
okay so we want basically a company
that's going to have huge cash flows and
then we want a management team that's
going to be able to handle those huge
cash flows properly because the
management team gets to destroy or
create value depending on what they do
they could buy back shares at the right
time or the wrong time or they could pay
a dividend at the right or wrong time
you could issue stock or issue debt at
the right or wrong time so you need uh
management in place that's highly
competent like top management teams in
the world and then we're looking to pay
a very fair value so traditionally we're
looking for great business models
growing businesses but deep value growth
businesses like the phil fisher kind of
growth
and great management teams
that's what we want to hold on to those
are going to compound in this scenario
what we're looking for is a company
that is going to be pretty
reasonably stable has a reasonably
stable business model over the next few
weeks we don't want something that's
going to sort of blow up or there's
going to be some big drawdown but as
long as it's uh
these are more in fact a lot of them end
up being kind of blue chip companies so
as you'll see we end up with like atn
t's and chevrons and exxon mobils and
things in this in this bucket so uh
these are just stable whales that for
some reason are paying a
statistically significant higher
dividend and also have volatility a bit
in their price which means these
premiums are high so that's really what
we're looking for in this scenario it's
a bit of a separation from some of the
traditional stuff that i've talked about
which is why i told you this is kind of
a unique
strategy especially in the value right
okay so it's gonna take some open-minded
value investors to get all the way to
this level i'll share one more quick
example basically i mentioned you can do
kkr
four times a year and it's actually not
the best example because it's such a
small dividend but looming technologies
uh they pay
a an eight percent dividend per year
which is two percent quarterly that sort
of becomes meaningful so
in this scenario what you have to look
at is what's what's the put expiration
date right before the ex dividend date
okay so go find the ex dividend of your
favorite security with a big dividend
and find the put right before it and
sell that put pretty much at the money
you want to get put the stock and you
want it to be a high enough dividends or
a high enough premium you're gonna have
to calculate the irr on the premium
against the collateral you need to hold
in this scenario we're just using these
dates your put expires november 19th
okay with a 12 strike and you get 58
cents these sound like they sound like
small numbers but because the time frame
is short it adds up so you're going to
get 58
uh cents on basically uh
11 and 42 cents in collateral okay
because that would add to your 12 strike
and then that expires november 19th
which is right before so then you take
possession of the stock in the event
that it gets put to you and if it
doesn't you still win because you keep
the premium and you're just done
but if it gets put to you
the next day you get a 25 cent dividend
on november 25th not the next day but
six days later okay so the ex-dividend
date is november 25th
and then immediately after that you can
sell a call and that call can expire
november 26th and we've actually changed
uh in in this is just an example here
where we've used a different strike
price we've said let's sell a call with
11.50 strike price so we're definitely
going to exit this and we pick up a 90
cent premium so we've picked up 58 cents
going in 25 cents on the dividend and
nine cents exiting uh and we basically
end up with a
10.8 percent return on our collateral
over 26 days
all right so
keep in mind
and jeremy you're you're a little
younger than i am so you've been
experiencing this massive bull run
uh for most of your life
but if you look through
centuries of data and you look at even
decades of data
the uh really consistent annualized
return of the markets is 6.8 per year
after inflation
and
it's very difficult for professionals to
beat that
uh what i'm showing you here is how to
make 10 in 26 days you could literally
pack up your office
if this works for you once
and go for the year and probably beat a
lot of people but you can do this four
times so
what this what happened next is i
started thinking well
what if we could just run capital
through a whole bunch of these what you
know it's it's hard when there's only
four
but if you can line up a whole lot of
these on their ex dividend dates are
different
then you can let's move capital crew
from one to the next and
um here's another example on mckesson by
the way this shows just a 7.5 percent
return over 33 days
but here's what ultimately you want to
get to
uh so these examples feed right into
this this is just in fact this will
probably
be valid with different prices
this october november december so
uh you basically
this is an example where we start with
one million dollars in october we start
with kkr we sell a put we get the stock
we get the dividend we sell a call we
exit now we move to chevron we sell a
put we get the stock we get the dividend
we sell a call we exit we move to lumen
mckesson occidental netease and seagate
and not all of them will work perfectly
but the returns are so astronomical that
you can afford to have a bunch of them
completely fail and you're still going
to make a huge return
in this flow diagram shows
a million turning into 1.8 million
in three months it's an 84 return in
three months time it's incredible it is
so lucrative the way you're getting paid
three times over a very brief period of
time
that in our parameters we actually don't
engage in any security that has less
than 100 irr so if it isn't going to
return over 100 per year
we just we just throw it away it's it's
just not worth it for us there's other
opportunities there's so many
opportunities like this that are paying
this amount and it's because of the
extreme volatility some prices are down
you know if they're maintaining their
dividends when the price is down the
dividend yield is up uh so you're
getting ball low price and a good
dividend deal yield and it's turning
into uh this type of opportunity now
i'll share also this with you
actually i'll go i'll go in two
directions first i'm going to point
something out that
everybody will want to know uh
this seems to be true and it looks like
it's it's not arbitrage but it's sort of
something
in the realm of i mean we're really
there's an anomaly in the market
how could this possibly exist
because if this existed it would be gone
it's like the old tale where the
professor says there's no 10 bill on the
floor because if there was somebody who
would have already picked it up so why
hasn't this been picked up
uh the reason is
these option contracts don't have
sufficient volume to accept billions in
capital flows which means none of the
smart money is in this space
goldman sachs is not playing this game
and even if they understood this
completely
it would not be worth their effort they
would have to hire people hire a desk
they'd have to feed it into all of their
systems they're never going to
participate in this
because they might max out running
say
50 or 100 million through it
uh and even if they're making 50 million
dollars that means it's meaningless okay
jp morgan doesn't care about this
opportunity uh
furthermore
this is sufficiently
complex
that most retail investors
would have no chance
of doing this successfully they would
they wouldn't even think to consider
this opportunity but if you're told it
in a simple way and it's laid out to you
i do believe you can implement it you
look at your high paying favorite
dividend stocks that have option
contracts and you just write a put that
expired before the dividend date and
this is what is going to happen for you
so um what's happened is basically
retail investors unfortunately are not
sophisticated enough to implement this
and smart investors have too much money
to participate in this space
and so it leaves it wide open for
those of us with say between
a million and a hundred million dollars
to manage
and so we can just
push capital through this
and make an absolute fortune there's one
more challenge which makes it uh even
more interesting and that is that the
analysis itself takes an enormous amount
of effort and most people aren't willing
to do it and then the prices are always
changing
the options are complex
and
so each quarter each month and each
quarter
you need to redo a very
time intensive analysis
and uh so when we first started looking
at this at our firm
uh it was during the 2020 uh year
pandemic and i started implementing it
in a test account that i run a real real
money test account a pa
and i started recognizing how lucrative
it was
and how time intensive it was
and i usually test things there before
um
uh putting things into the portfolio so
uh
i realized that this was a
massive opportunity we were just we were
just making such an extraordinary term
um with a with a small amount of capital
with about
000 we were just sort of doubling it it
was very easy to do in terms of time
intensiveness like
of course there's no number you could
say but for you personally like how many
hours per week do you think that that
took to
really see this be effective and
lucrative i've already done the hard
work for you jeremy and all your viewers
this is the this is the answer
uh but so
what would it be it's it's sort of like
i was just thinking about it for an hour
a day for a while and then when you
actually sit down and start doing the
analysis
you start spending complete afternoons
a couple times a week so maybe you're
spending four hours on something so
maybe it's eight hours a week for
i mean it took a lo a while it took
about eight ten weeks and you're also
trading and implementing and testing it
right i'm not certain that it's gonna
work properly i'm not confident to put
it in the portfolio uh so i had to i had
to
test this uh i had to
recognize i had to look up
all sorts of uh
nuances okay there's some there's some
tax ramifications jeremy that we can
touch on maybe i'll just mention now
that unfortunately instead of having
long-term capital gains that i'm very
accustomed to or even just totally
deferred capital gains because my i'm
holding on to a business that's just
compounding and not realizing any gains
this is all taxed at your personal
income right including the dividend
because you didn't even hold it um to
get preferential dividend treatment but
the
gains are so high
that it's worth paying the taxes it's
like if there's twenty dollars sitting
on the floor and if you pick it up you
have to pay
35 percent to the government
you're still going to pick up the 20
lane there
and that's exactly what we're doing it's
this is it's such an obvious incredible
situation but the time intensiveness is
challenging so you can do it in a less
sophisticated manner maybe you just have
five dividend stocks and that wouldn't
be that time intensity you might grab a
few of these you might have your own
favorite companies uh
you know there's there's a few oil
companies and and
att even icon enterprises always seems
like a fairly good one you can just get
a good premium and then they pay an
eight percent annual dividend so you get
a two percent dividend and then you get
out
uh with a call
and and and i'll i'll add something to
this and this is where you do need this
is why it's 4.0 instead of being
or
401 this is like to the 401 level it's
because you really need to understand
how transacting in options works so so
that you don't get caught off guard so
if you sell a put and the put expires
out of the money that's fine you just
would move to kkr to chevron that's not
an issue you just pick you don't make a
full seven percent that week you might
make two percent that week but that's
okay you just made two percent a week if
you get put the shares uh and then you
sell a call and the shares decline and
you don't exit that's also okay you just
need to sell another call the next week
and depending how you've rolled your
capital together we're actually using a
basket so i've simplified this a lot to
show one
particular cash flow stream but it's not
really how it looks how it really looks
is kkr would be balanced with another 10
securities that are all expiring
at the same day so actually every week
we're rolling a basket and so if a few
of them if a few of them decline in
price and the calls you know we don't
get called away we still own the shares
that's actually not that big of a deal
at all we could actually make more money
by just selling a call that expires next
week and then selling call expires next
week and every single week we're just
picking up another one or two percent as
long as the call premium is outweighing
the decline in stock price uh we're
still at a net positive and uh and even
if one we we actually
expect sort of over the long term or
normal distribution so we expect some to
work very well most be somewhere in the
middle and a few in our basket to not
work well so there's always going to be
a couple that fall in price and then we
sell calls we sell calls we sell calls
and we exit
and so
we need to have sufficient gains in the
other positions to offset a few or a
couple that might not work out well for
us so if at t gets cut in half
that's very unfortunate but we'll end up
in our basket with a few of those over
time uh we just need to make up for that
we're looking at probabilistic thinking
we're looking at you know averages and
every because let's say that we're in 10
let's say we're in 10 positions in our
basket at once
uh we would only have let's say we have
15 exposure in our whole portfolio we
have 10 positions in our basket what
that means is any particular position is
just one and a half percent portfolio we
are a very constantly portfolio some of
our positions are 18 19 percent daily
journal is a big one for us
around that number for example uh
a one and a half percent position is not
a concern and if it falls in half we're
still getting put premiums called
premiums dividends uh so we're not
losing half
and so we're losing less than half of
one and a half percent okay so just put
it all in context so this is a very
simplified explanation
uh i think your viewers can take
a handful of their favorite high
dividend paying stock and lay them out
and do it with
do it casually
uh without a lot of time intensiveness
what we needed to do
properly
was build a python script and automate
this whole thing
so basically what we've done
is uh i hired an intern i don't write
script but i know what we needed and
thanks to actually some
presentations at valuex with guys spear
i knew that it needed to be in python
which was a huge towel
so i hired a
developer
and we basically
built out a system that we could run so
instead of it taking
weeks to figure out what that capital
flow would look like with all these
baskets it just takes a couple hours and
we run this script so we pull all the
13f data into spreadsheets all the 100
you know different funds that we're
analyzing and we look at the superset
then we go to a capital iq and we pull
down all of the financial data into the
spreadsheet so we can look at what is uh
for example
uh what are the dividend yields you know
how stable are these companies at a high
level is there is a really bad ratios
like is there debt putting the company
at risk we can throw out things that are
of concern and then how many remain and
jeremy when we do it this way
we might have 500 companies on the
superset analysis
of our 13fs it shrinks to about
maybe 60 companies
that have high dividends that are stable
firm they don't need to be stable in
price but they need to have stability
within their businesses so it shrinks
immediately to 60 and then we can go
through quickly i can go through
manually and throw out companies i don't
like uh so there is a little overlay
where we just say we're not going to get
involved in that there's you know that
could go wrong uh and then finally the
python script goes out and grabs all
sorts of option data so we can analyze
the greeks and we can look at what the
premiums would be
and
you can see on the right this is
literally the output from our script so
i'm just showing your viewers the answer
here
we get a 13f supercent analysis right on
top then we get all the financial data
plugged in in the middle and it just
highlights and runs macros and it's it's
pretty uh
it's a little bit complex but but it's
uh
but
but it can be done uh we've done it and
and your viewers can do it
and then finally at the end it actually
builds out this flow diagram where it
lists the companies
that fit our parameters with above 100
irs that have options with huge premiums
where the puts are
uh you know puts are
being sold and expiring right before the
ex dividend date and we can get the
stock we can get the dividend we can get
the call premium we can exit and that's
exactly what we get down on the bottom
right
and it basically lays out how we're
going to flow our capital for the next
quarter and we just start implementing
that and we're just seeing gains of and
we're doing it actually conservatively
but we're still seeing double-digit
gains
quarterly
implementing this strategy wow
yeah
how clear
how clear was that jeremy could you
follow uh i think that worked all right
yeah no yeah that was uh uh amazing um
seeing seeing you break it down like
that um and then so
in terms of like okay so you built out
this system
here are the things that you know if
we're really
going to put in the work to do this
ourselves and move through the you know
one two step three step and then
eventually get the four step and take
those baby steps
at that level so i'm so step one looking
for uh stable companies
uh that have a high dividend yield that
and then looking at companies that based
on my own experiences and and morals and
etc that i don't like and toss those out
then looking at the greeks and premiums
to see does this get above 100 irr
yeah and looking at
and annualized and then from that
knowing that data it's then a matter of
saying okay when does their ex dividend
date end and then how do we find the
closest expiration date of the options
congratulations jeremy you got it all
right perfect so as you implement this
you'll find there's a lot of unique
situations that pop up so i recommend
just going slow start with you don't
need to do the full 13 f analysis and
i'm gonna also take one more tangent to
what you said and point out it's a very
special
uh
advantage to start looking at high
quality 13fs okay you can just go to
scc.gov you can pull down 13f
for anybody who doesn't know the 13 f's
just snapshot of the portfolio holdings
of a
of a of a
super investor so
if you go to a 13f it helps you
eliminate a whole bunch of errors i
think if you start from the standpoint
of who's paying the highest dividend you
might find yourself in a in a
bad situation where where you buy a
company with an unsustainable dividend
or
where the shares price is really falling
so i think it's more appropriate to
come at it from the lens of what's the
greatest business out there and then are
there any of these that have a high
dividend
and one way to do that a shortcut way
rather than just screening because what
would you really be screening for
you you go look at some 13 f's and you
say okay so you know this company shows
up a whole lot of times it's owned by
you know whoever your favorite investors
are but it can be sitting there in you
know warren buffett's portfolio and
charlie munger's portfolio and manish
pabrai owns it as well so you know what
okay it's probably pretty reasonable uh
and it happens to be paying an
extraordinary dividend and when you find
yourself in that situation you can use
these option contracts uh as a smaller
investor
to just rip these dividends out of the
market and um and and so i i just want
to point out it's really important to
start from the lens of what's great
business and then what where is it high
dividend not where is the high dividend
and can i make this work
and i guess even though um this is your
20 capital is say different than your
long term strategy
um
extremely high conviction on each bet
you make
the margin of safety does come into
looking at the guru investors who
like that's where the margin of safety
does lie yeah well the margin of safety
is also in just lowering your strike
price and things like that but it's but
you're
um mitigating your risk
in a certain manner look when you're so
i always get these challenges with the
efficient market hypothesis because if
the efficient market hypothesis were
true even though it's a noble prize
winning hypothesis
uh firms like berkshire hathaway
wouldn't exist because there would be no
way for them to like consistently be
growing faster than the market it
wouldn't
you know
it says that that's impossible so we
know that it's not totally true
but the problem is that doesn't mean
that it's
not true at all it's actually mostly
true so most securities are priced
accurately most of the time and you need
to be turning over so many stones to
find a missed price security if you
start from the approach of like a 13 f
analysis
you're looking for needles in a haystack
anyway but if you look at 13 f's i think
you're finding a lot more needles
uh
than than hey in in that basket of
security so i think you reduce your risk
of making an error um
you know there's a lot of conviction
behind behind those positions that
they're gonna uh appreciate but we
recently saw we see a lot of mistakes
and errors happen okay we see bill
ackman
uh buy in and sell out of netflix and
lose a bunch of money and uh and so you
can't just blindly you know
everyone makes errors and everyone has
either and there's probabilistic
thinking involved
uh and so it's you don't want to do this
and implement it blindly but if you have
some great companies in the back your
mind that you
know pay a a good dividend uh you can go
in and implement this uh and and
probably do very well wow yeah that was
a amazing thank you so much for breaking
that down uh really making sure that we
i i mean i understood the process i will
re-watch this and re-watch this um thank
you going through this i'll i'll add
just a couple a
really quick additional point um and
maybe for some maybe this works for a
retail investor with a big salary
um it certainly works for a fund manager
like us because we're we're bringing in
capital almost on a monthly basis and we
need to allocate that capital
fortunately we have way more ideas than
capital uh but you asked a good question
earlier and it's like we treat this as
one position
and it's about 15 to 20
of our portfolio uh but when we we would
prefer even though this is so lucrative
it's time consuming there's uh uh
there's taxes involved uh and and also
jeremy this will not always work so you
can't this this is not something that
you can just implement through
watch the vix as like a macro indicator
even though i don't really like my macro
like that it's a micro
level vol that matters
but if the fix is high
this is probably going to be working
well because you're getting high
premiums for your securities fear is
high so puts are costly and sore calls
uh if the vix is low
and the world just seems
to be moving along perfectly
you're not going to get sufficient
premiums and this isn't going to work
and it's not especially not going to be
worth it after you pay commissions and
taxes so
uh so you need to be able to move in and
out of this strategy when it's working
and then stop when it's not working uh
the second thing to point out is as a
fund we're always raising capital and so
a lot of times you feel even though
we're very patient long-term investors
you feel the pressure to put cash to
work we don't mind holding cash
but uh but there is a pressure to put
things to work otherwise it lo otherwise
it's a drag on the portfolio
this allows us to immediately put cash
to work it comes in and we just
put it right into the structured
dividend capture
program
and then as soon as we have a new
allocation we can allocate you know to a
10 long term holding uh and we just pull
it right out of this so this is a this
is like
use of our cash while it's waiting for
a great long-term compounding
opportunity and
and so it can help people who have high
salaries anybody who's bringing capital
can implement this over the short term
until they find
their new best great long-term
investment idea yeah and yeah um it's
just it's so interesting to see like you
know studying warren buffett and charlie
and
looking at a lot of value investors it's
it's a lot of these guys aren't
one-trick ponies as well
they they can maneuver in the certain
areas that we're in and so this just
does seem
yeah like
adding something to the tool belt
for when the time is appropriate
warren buffett recently bought a bunch
of activision
and uh
you know i don't know if you caught this
but he said in in the annual meeting
that he just clarified for everybody and
he said look our activision is basically
a workout that we used to do from the
1960s microsoft's gonna buy it they
offered xyz price they have the cash we
think it's probably going to go through
and the shares were selling at a
discount so over a few months we just
make 15 or something so they just bought
billions of dollars in activision and
that is not
a long-term
traditional ben graham value
play it's a it's like an info arbitrage
almost play it's like it's a uh it's
taking advantage of a
of a corporate uh event and um and so
truly these these legendary investors
they are pivoting
and maneuvering even at large scale
through these different strategies and
so um although we're a long-term value
fund
you know we are not opposed to just when
there's money laying around we just
going to grab it and uh and i think a
lot of your viewers are probably
sophisticated enough to dabble in this
and the ones that do will find that it's
extremely lucrative it'd be fun to learn
what what companies people like
yeah and not starting with 15 20 percent
just you know starting at maybe you know
three to five percent max and then once
you get more comfortable you start hey i
i can understand this and i know that's
what i'll be doing personally as as just
trying to take baby steps as this so
that you don't lose uh you know uh all
your money um and and even for the folks
that have never dabbled in options you
just upgrade your brokerage account or
whatnot and you get to this sort of
situation where you can write contracts
and then you look for a company with a
high dividend and you just write one and
it expires before the dividend you're
probably gonna do okay um you have a lot
of things working your favor
as long as you like the firm and it's
good company you're gonna receive a put
premium that's gonna give you a margin
of safety below the market price then
you're going to get a dividend and as
you exit with a call you'll get another
premium
it's highly likely that you will make
some profit uh the first one or two
might be a little bit of work but as you
get comfortable i i i think i think most
your viewers can go and try this once uh
and and be pretty comfortable that it's
gonna do okay wow well well thank you so
much yeah this was amazing and i do want
to be respectful of your time so um uh
yeah i'd love for you to tell people
where they can find you uh learn more
about you
absolutely
so so i run up on peterson capital
management um our fund our website is
petersonfunds.com and we literally have
11 years of quarterly letters annual
letters where i talk about all of this
in fact some of the diagrams i just
showed you are available in our 2021
annual letters so people can go and look
up that information there
on our website we also have a
uh
growing youtube channel uh thanks thanks
jeremy for all of your of your advice on
that
and uh
yeah i'm on twitter i'm on social media
but i think youtube and the website are
great ways to to reach out and um and
people can always email me and my emails
uh i'm not too hard to find perfect and
i i will put a link in the description
to check out uh matthew's uh
youtube channel as that scales up so
be sure to see the link in description
and his website but thank you again for
for coming on and sharing all this
valuable wisdom
thank you jeremy it's a pleasure to see
you again pleasure to be here if you
like that video check out this video
with guy spear on how to build wealth
right here and i'll see you there
investing is an infinite game jeff bezos
he doesn't walk around saying look how
rich i am if anything he says look at
the amazing company that i've built